مناظر خلابة قلاع مهيبة على
مدى قرون من التاريخ ، وادي لوار هو
أحد جواهر التاج للسياحة الفرنسية التي
تجذب ستة ملايين زائر
سنويًا من جميع أنحاء العالم ، وهي صناعة
أصابها فيروس كورونا بالشلل بعد
قرابة شهرين من الحبس الوطني
ومع إغلاق الحدود في الغالب
للسائحين الخارجيين والآن سلعة نادرة
كانت مملوكة
لملكة فرنسا من قبل.
في الواقع ، السبب الوحيد
الذي جعل شاتو قادرًا على إعادة فتحه هو
أنه توجد هنا أيضًا
أقنعة توجيهية صارمة للتباعد الاجتماعي على
يديك ، وهناك طريق محدد
مسبقًا يجب عليك اتباعه من خلال المجال
وتم تحديد عدد الزوار
بالترتيب  لتجنب الازدحام ، لقد
مضى وقت طويل منذ أن لم نخرج ،
لذلك نشعر بالرضا فقط عدد قليل من
الزوار اليوم ، كلهم من ال
كان المحليين لا يزالون يسافرون  على بعد
مائة كيلومتر من نصف قطرها ، كان لدى مارتين
وجان ماري بعيدًا خططًا لزيارة
الدنمارك وأوزبكستان هذا الصيف والتي
سيتعين عليها الانتظار بطريقة هذه الفترات
جيدة جدًا ، وغالبًا ما ننسى زيارة هذه
المواقع الجميلة في فرنسا لكنها
دولة رائعة شاتو  لا
تتوقع أن ترى زوارها الأجانب المعتادون
هذا الصيف حول ثلث
أعمالها كما يقولون ، لكن مدير المجال
يرى جانبًا إيجابيًا آمل
أن تأتي الزيادة في الزوار الفرنسيين
لأنهم لا يستطيعون السفر إلى الخارج
سيعوضون عنها  الزوار الأجانب الذين
للأسف لن يتمكنوا من القدوم إلى هنا في
باريس ، ولكن لا توجد بطانة فضية
في الأفق ، حيث تظل مناطق الجذب الرئيسية
مغلقة برج إيفل
والقوارب النهرية ليست بعيدة عن هنا ، حيث يتم إغلاق
متحف Triomphe the Lula النشط.
أذكر المطاعم والمقاهي ، وبما أن
باريس لا تزال تعتبر منطقة حمراء
لفيروس كورونا ، فلا أحد يعلم
متى يُسمح بإعادة
افتتاح أي منها بحوالي 90 مليون طن.  موظفونا في
العام ، تعد فرنسا الدولة الأكثر زيارة
في العالم
الأسبوع الماضي ، وقد قال رئيس الوزراء الفرنسي إن
إنقاذ الصناعة كان أولوية وطنية
، وتشمل حزمة الإنقاذ الحكومية
للقطاع ضمان القروض
المصرفية للشركات ودفع 80 في المائة
من رواتب العمال الذين تم إجازتهم.
ين ، مالك ومدير فندقين
ومطعم في قلب باريس ،
إنه شريان حياة
كان حجزه الأخير في 12 مارس مخيفًا
بفضل قرض بقيمة 250 ألف يورو يأمل
أن يتمكن من البقاء على قيد الحياة خلال
الأشهر القليلة المقبلة ولكنه في أمس الحاجة إلى
إعادة فتح الحدود و  السفر للالتقاط ، نحتاج
إلى أشخاص للطيران مرة أخرى ، السياحة هي
طائرات لا طائرات ، إنها تقيد حقًا
عدد الجولات التي سنقوم
بها حتى ذلك الحين ،
سيحصل الباريسيون على شوارع
العاصمة لأنفسهم ،
يا رفاق ، هذا هو يوم عمل واحد
اليوم الخامس أعتقد أنه يجب أن يكون يومًا مع
الدلافين والشواطئ البكر ، فهناك
أماكن أسوأ للعزل الذاتي من
جزيرة صحراوية ، لذلك عندما تغادر آخر
رحلة من أرخبيل M&E في سقطرى ،
بقيت مدونة الفيديو للسفر Ava zubik ، لقد جئت إلى هنا و le March لأجري
ماراثونًا هنا وقمت بتشغيله ،
لكن نوعًا منكم تعلم أن العالم بدأ في
الإغلاق من حولنا وانتهى بي
الأمر بالبقاء في الجزيرة  منذ أكثر من
شهرين وليس لديها أي فكرة عن موعد
عودتها إلى المنزل على عكس أرضها
التي دمرتها الحرب وهي سلمية بشكل عام ،
فهي أحد مواقع التراث العالمي
لليونسكو وما قبل الوباء كانت تستقبل
رحلة ركاب واحدة فقط في الأسبوع لـ zubik
الذي يسافر إلى أماكن  معظم الناس لم
يكن ذلك جزءًا من جاذبية الحياة
على الجزيرة بطيئة جدًا ، إنها بسيطة جدًا في
الواقع
ولا تحتوي الجزيرة على
مراكز تسوق أو سينما ، وعادة ما ينتهي بي الأمر
بالاستيقاظ عند شروق الشمس والصوم مع
العائلة التي تستضيفني هنا  في
قرية جبلية صغيرة ، قرأت ، أكتب أنني
أتجول في الجبال ، كان
هناك شخص ما على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ينتقدك لعودتك في
المقام الأول إلى احتمال إدخال
الفيروس  إلى الجزيرة في بداية
شهر مارس ، لم نكن ندرك مدى
خطورة الأمر وأتذكر أنني نظرت في
جميع أنواع إرشادات السفر ، لذلك
لم يتبق سوى بضعة أيام بعد
تصاعد الموقف وفجأة تغيرت نصيحة السفر
180  تم
فحص درجاتنا بالفعل عند الدخول عند الوصول إلى
سقطرى وهذا طمأننا بأننا
لن نقدم أي شيء إلى
سقطرى ولكني أحاول المساهمة
في سكان الجزيرة من خلال التواجد هنا
بأي طريقة يمكنني من خلالها ما يبدو وكأنه
لقد اتخذت فرصة لتمديد هذا اليوم في الجنة منعطفًا ، وأصبحت الأسابيع الآن
شهورًا أريدها كل يوم
يأتي
، سأكون هنا وفي غضون أسبوعين في غضون
ثلاثة أو أربعة أسابيع ، يبدأ موسم الرياح الموسمية ،
لذلك أشعر بالقلق حيال ذلك
أعتقد أنه إذا اضطررت إلى اختيار ما إذا كانت هناك
رحلة غدًا ، أعتقد أنني سأستقلها على الأرجح
عندما نصل إلى هنا ، ظهرت الرسالة
في الأخبار وكنت أفكر في
ما يجري
[موسيقى]
[م  usic]
نعم الآن ، حسنًا ، يقول الناس أنه
حتى في المواقف العادية ولا
أعرف ربما يكون الوقت الآن أفضل لأنه
كما قال نوح نحن بعيدون عن
الجميع ، من السهل عزلني
أشعر بمزيد من الحرية
[  موسيقى]
يبدو الأمر إلى حد ما أننا
كنا نستعد لهذا ، من فضلك ، من السهل ،
إنها تبدو كإمبراطور صغير جالس
على هذا الكرسي ، فماذا كنت
تطعم سيارا فهي تحب البروكلي
تشعر بقدر ما نفعله  على
YouTube شهدنا زيادة بنسبة 300٪ تقريبًا
، ويشاهد الأشخاص مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بنا
والتي تفهم أن الأشخاص في
المنزل يبدون مثاليين ، ولكن ليس
من الرائع أيضًا أن
تكون مكتفيًا ذاتيًا وأننا
نعلم أننا ندير  الغسالة الخاصة بنا من
الألواح الشمسية نحن نقوم بصرف
طعامنا الذي نعرفه مثل كل
الأشياء المكتفية ذاتيًا أعتقد أنها
أصبحت أكثر وأكثر إثارة للاهتمام
للناس أيضًا ، وهو أمر رائع خطتنا طويلة الأجل
التي أحبها فقط  كن عائلة
على المحيط  إنه تايلور ، سأعمل على إنشاء
مقاطع فيديو على YouTube وأنت تعلم أنها
رائعة وأحبها
مثل أحد الأشياء التي نشعر
بالامتنان لها حقًا هو أنه يمكننا قضاء 24
ساعة في اليوم 7 أيام في الأسبوع
معًا في الطقس الممطر والكئيب ولكن
لا يمكن أن يكون المزاج السائد بين سائقي السيارات
أفضل حيث تم إعادة فتح العديد من المعابر الحدودية
بين ألمانيا
والنمسا ، حيث خططت النمسا وألمانيا
لإعادة فتح حدودهما بالكامل بحلول 15 يونيو
كجزء من جهد أوروبي أكبر
لإعادة حرية حركة الأشخاص
وإحياء  صناعة السياحة في غيبوبة
مع ضمان عدم وجود
تفشي آخر على بعد دقائق قليلة من
الحدود ، تقع سالزبورغ المهيبة ،
مسقط رأس فولفغانغ أماديوس
موزارت زايد ، وهي عادة ما تكون نقطة جذب
للسياح مع الأشخاص القادمين ليس فقط
من جميع أنحاء أوروبا ولكن من جميع أنحاء أوروبا
العالم الآن بالطبع
توقف كل ذلك بشكل مفاجئ عندما
ضرب الوباء ولكن الآن على الأقل هناك
بصيص أمل في أن يتمكن بعض الزوار من
العودة في  ليس مستقبلًا بعيدًا جدًا بالنسبة
لمالك آنا باخمان
لبيانات الألعاب الأولمبية الشهيرة ولكن بمعزل عن الألعاب الأولمبية ، يبدأ المستقبل
الآن مع السماح بافتتاح المطاعم
منذ يوم الجمعة يقول باخمان إنه
متفائل بأن الأعمال التجارية ستستعيد
احتياجات الناس المتفائلة بالحاجة إلى إظهارها ،
لكن الفنادق مثل مدافع الصرف الصحي يجب أن تفعل
ذلك  انتظر لفترة أطول حتى 29 مايو
، حيث شهدت المنطقة المحجوزة في الموقع
طفرة سياحية في السنوات الأخيرة
، يقول ممثل السياحة في المنطقة إن
استعادة الزوار أمر
حيوي ، ونتوقع خسارة في الإيرادات
بنسبة 25 ٪ تقريبًا للعام بأكمله ، لذا
فهي ضخمة وبالطبع نحن كذلك
يتطلع كل من ألمانيا والنمسا إلى إعادة التشغيل مرة أخرى ،
حيث قال كل منهما إنهما حريصان على
إحياء السفر والسياحة بين
البلدين ، لكن كل هذا يتوقف على
ما إذا كان بإمكانهما الاستمرار في التغلب
على الوباء